[Musique]
tranquillement les églises de montréal
reprennent vie à la paroisse saint nom
de jésus dans hochelaga maisonneuve
les messes ont recommencé et avec le
retour des paroissiens le retour de la
quête
ici elle rapporte environ 400 dollars
par semaine à la paroisse de l'argent
que l'église ne recevait plus depuis
mars
c'est assez dramatique comme pertes au
niveau des paroisses les cas est l'hedim
ne sont pas entrées du tout depuis six
semaines
ça commence à peine à recommencer mais
il ya aussi tous les aspects des
locations pour la culture saucisse est
extrêmement important donc tout ce qui
est spectacle tous les concerts tout ce
qui est en activité de location culturel
tout ça est disparue depuis ça reviendra
pas tout de suite
[Musique]
robert allard célèbre à nouveau cms mais
la paroisse ne peut plus le payer
il touche la prestation canadienne
d'urgence josquin a eu l'aide du fédéral
pour assurer un peu de revenus pour des
employés qui ont perdu leurs salaires on
a comme été mises à pied bon oeil
compris donc le pce fédéral a soutenu
c'est extrêmement important mais en a
qu'on avait plus de revenus les vertus
rentrer encore coordonnatrice pour la
paroisse jenny du m
elle aussi reçoit la pcu avant la
pandémie dit elle saint nom de jésus
était déjà en déficit de 150 3000 $ pour
cette année c'est de regarder pas payer
chauffage doit payer l'électricité de
regarder à pouvoir payer nos dépenses
telles qu'elles ne pas avoir des
salariés
c'est donc jésus est loin d'être la
seule paroisse à vivre une crise
financière
le diocèse de montréal qui en compte
deux sens sur l'île de montréal à laval
et dans lanaudière traverse une période
difficile
l'archevêque christian lépine estime qu
environ 400 employés reçoivent la pcu
actuellement là où c'est plus difficile
ce qui est des paroisses qui étaient
déjà fragilisées
non on peut parler d'une quarantaine de
parole quand même joué en difficulté
souvent c'est relié au milieu dans un
milieux démunis
il ya plus de difficultés dans le sens
que des fois il arrive à leurs dépenses
courantes mais dès que des travaux à
faire
là ils sont pas capables de faire
et des travaux à faire il y en a
plusieurs églises montréalaises sont en
piteux état et de nombreuses autres pour
elle de venir
l'église du très-saint-nom-de-jésus par
exemple à des infiltrations d'eau
importante entre autres les travaux sont
évalués à 10 millions de dollars sur dix
ans et comment vous allez pas encore
payé
c'est celle là qui est fière c'est
d'avoir des mécènes j'annonce donc sans
plus tarder
québec annoncé le 20 juillet un
investissement de 15 millions de dollars
d'ici 2021 pour restaurer le patrimoine
religieux de la province toutes
religions confondues l'île de montréal
aura seulement droit à deux millions et
demi si monseigneur lépine
on aurait 50 millions de dollars puis on
classerait y avait des travaux pour 50
millions de dollars dans un parc dans
les églises peuple à 200 églises parce
que quand vinrent encore une fois un
toit c'est un million fait savoir assez
vite au lieu du catholicisme à montréal
même la basilique notre-dame visité par
plus d'un million de personnes par année
éprouvent de grosses difficultés
financières
[Musique]
l'annulation du spectacle son et lumière
aura lui fait perdre beaucoup d'argent
l'absence de touristes et le respect des
règles sanitaires antico vide ne
permettent pas non plus de reprendre les
visites payantes pour que je sois
rentable depuis le confinement donc on a
dû mettre à pied près de 80% de nous
employer une trentaine à l'heure
actuelle avec l'effondrement de la haute
saison touristique
on anticipe des pertes de revenus pour
20 de près de 12 millions de dollars
pour nous ces revenus sont absolument
nécessaires pour préserver restaurer le
bâtiment istres est un joyau patrimonial
qui aura 200 ans en 2029 et qui d'ici là
aura besoin de 30 millions de dollars
pour rester en bon état la phase 1 des
travaux est d'ailleurs commencé j'ai
commencé à faire un premier tour des
élus politiques pour les sensibiliser à
notre situation demandé l'aide de la
lettre du gouvernement
dans la situation actuelle parce que la
crise accélère l'urgence d'agir et et
nos besoins financiers pour les travaux
christian lépine lance un appel à ses
fidèles son église a besoin d'argent
mais seulement vraiment un effort de
solidarité faut que les gens se on évite
les gens disent oui c'est vrai ça fait
quatre mois que quatre mois je dois pas
la messe mais
je veux aider ma paroisse je veux aider
mon église où je veux aider la
communauté
ils recherchent aussi des partenaires
pour des projets qui sauveront la
structure de ces églises plusieurs par
exemple ont déjà été convertis en
appartement ou en centre communautaire
le diocèse de montréal en est là il
n'avait certainement pas besoin de l'aco
vie ici jean-sébastien cloutier
radio-canada m'ont rien